I don't even now Senator Mike Lee Senate
Judiciary Committee Member and author of
saving nine the fight against the left's
audacious plan to pack the Supreme Court
and Destroy American Liberty and Senator
speaking um of this complete disregard
for our institutions you saw what Biden
did today
in uh in Madrid I want to bring it back
to something else that the president
said overseas
the most important thing to be clear
about is we have to change I believe we
have to codify Roe v Wade in the law and
the way to do that is to make sure the
Congress votes to do that and if the
filibuster gets in the way it's like
voting rights it should be we provide an
exception for this
the convulsion over the court continues
and it's now being aided by our
president abroad
your reaction
this is appalling Laura first of all the
fact that he would go while on foreign
soil and attack the Supreme Court of the
United States to undermine it and to
delegitimize it is unpatriotic I've
never seen anything quite like it
um secondly insofar as he's suggesting
that they need to codify Roe he's he's
lying there they don't merely want to
codify Roe what they want to do is pass
a bill that would in addition to
codifying row it would take the
protections of Roe all the way up until
the moment a child takes its first
breath so that no state anywhere could
impose any kind of legal restrictions
any kind of protections for unborn human
beings so he managed to be at once um
entirely heartless toward The Unborn
entirely in conflict with his own prior
decisions his own prior statements about
abortion well as a U.S senator and
otherwise and managed to disrespect one
of the great institutions of our system
look warts and all the Supreme Court of
the United States isn't a bad Court it
is a good court and the fact that it's a
run by uh mortal human beings means they
sometimes make mistakes they did not
make a mistake with Dobbs they corrected
a mistake they had made 49 years earlier
this is unacceptable Behavior I don't
know whether to chalk it up to
incompetence or avarice or both but this
is not going to fly with the American
people well Senator Ed Markey today was
talking about why it's so important for
the Democrats to finally what they
wanted to do is to get rid of the
filibuster
the filibuster has to be amended uh or
it has to be eliminated otherwise we're
just going to see not just in this area
but gun rights and climate and uh in so
many other areas just an evisceration of
rights that Americans have come to
depend upon
Senator I I think the truth is that the
left now hates the court because it's
the only branch that still respects the
original framework of the Constitution
at least as it's currently currently
situated with the justices that are on
board
yeah that's right and make no mistake
this idea of nuking the filibuster in
addition to being in conflict with what
Joe Biden has said in very recent years
about the fact that it would be a bad
idea
this is not limited to their so-called
attempt to codify Roe no that's just the
first step they the real objective there
is to expand the Supreme Court to pack
the Supreme Court which is explained in
Saving nine is one of the most
disastrous things they could do to the
Constitution it's not technically
unconstitutional but it's
anti-constitutional it would have wrote
everything about it and Ed Markey as
explaining saving nine is one of the
original architects of this modern plan
to do it but every time this has been
attempted in in modern history Laura it
has ended badly for the American people
whether it succeeds or fails
legislatively
Senator this idea of codifying Road just
because a lot of people have have been
inquiring about this I don't know what
the legislation would would look like or
specifically say
I guess there's a draft of it already
written but I haven't read it but what
were the you know two or three
challenges that the states would Lodge
against such an effort other than
obvious State states rights and the 10th
Amendment yeah so first of all they
would they would perhaps argue that this
is outside of congress's authority to
enact sweeping Nationwide legislation
like this you know you've got to
actually have a jurisdictional hook in
there somewhere and depends on on what
ground they rested on but let's assume
just for a minute that they use the
Commerce Clause which is what Congress
typically uses for almost any type of
legislation it passes uh abortion is
itself not an economic activity it's
certainly not an economic activity that
takes place across state lines typically
um and so those might be some of the
challenges that they would Lodge against
it but the legislation itself may or may
not be upheld at the end of the day you
know as well as anyone Laura the Supreme
Court has been fairly permissive and
deferential to Congress in defining the
Contours of the Commerce Clause and
that's also something I'll talk about in
Saving nine that is a the
ugly gift that keeps on giving that came
about as a result of FDR's Court packing
plan 85 years ago but at the end of the
day okay what they want to do is make
sure that infanticide is legal
yeah they don't they don't want the
people to have their own ability to
determine their own Destinies and
Futures in every state they hate that
back to the point that a lot of them
just really don't like America or
founding documents they want to if they
could they would I think they would get
rid of it all and replace it with
something much more akin to what governs
the EU Senator it's great to see you
tonight thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else